हुआ था नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि
नए एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है लास्ट
एपिसोड में हमने भी वन एग्जामिनेशन कर लें
जब आयरन पार्ट देखे थे इस बार हमेशा
ह्यूमन देखने वाले हैं श्रवण मेरे हिसाब
से सबसे इजी और सबसे स्कोरिंग टाइल है
मुझे खुद उसमें 99 में और मार्क आए थे और
मैंने जितने सारे स्टूडेंट जो हमसे सीखे
उन सबके लिए ही यह हमेशा एक स्कोरिंग
स्टाइल रहिए है तो अभी हम उसके थोड़े से
एग्जाम का पैटर्न और उसके टिप्स देते हैं
तो सबसे पहले अगर आप स्किन में आप देख रहे
होंगे तो मैं इन जनरल थोड़ा सा कम समय में
पैटर्न बताता हूं जो इसमें आपको क्या करना
है पिछले तीन चीज़े लिखनी है जो मेसेज
लिखने हैं इमेज और एक अपना ओपिनियन लिखना
है तो पहले देखे पहले आपको एक इन फॉर्मल
ईमेल लिखना है वह क्या है डिटेल में हम
देखेंगे एक इन फॉर्मल ईमेल लिखना है 80
वर्ड्स मतलब कितने 10 से 15 लाइन 40 मार्ग
के लिए ऊ
यहां पर आपको अपना ओपिनियन लिखना है
अज्ञेय स्टीवर्ड 10 से 15 लाइन 40 मार के
लिए और एंड मैं आपको यह फॉर्मल यह फॉर्मन
ईमेल लिखना है उसमें आपके लिप्स 20 मार्क
है उसके लिए कुछ 40 वर्ड मतलब पांच से सात
सेंटेंस लिखने हैं तो यह और अलग रख दें और
25 से 30 सेंटेंस लिखोगे टोटला देखो कि
चाहे ज़ूम कुछ छह परसेंट मतलब सिक्सटी मार
के लिए पास है और प्रीटी सिंपल पर आप जहां
बहुत से लोगों की गलती होती है कहां पर कि
इसका मार्किंग कैसे है समझने में इसे लिए
इन डिटेल इन टाइल्स में जाने से पहले हम
इसकी मार्किंग सिस्टम समझ लेते हैं तो
आपको सबसे पहले यह तीनों टाइल्स के लिए एक
ही मार्किंग सिस्टम को डिवैलप सेट किया
जाएगा 14 पॉइंट पर रिक्वेस्ट किया जाएगा
वह कौन से हम देखते हैं पहले भी फ्यूल
लूंगी एग्जिक्यूटिव मतलब टेक्निकली फुल
फिल्म है वह आपको जो भी टेस्ट दिया है
मतलब
वॉइस मेल में मामलों में फॉर्मल मेल में
जो भी डाल दिया है उस पर अपने कंप्लीट
किया है कि वह अगर आपको तीन पॉइंट्स है तो
तीन पॉइंट पर लिखा है क्या इसके लिए होता
है रिफ्यूलिंग यह अपने अपने खुद के मार्क
है यह बिल्कुल ध्यान नहीं देने ओके उसके
बाद नेक्स्ट होता है को रहेंगे कॉइन जस्ट
लाइक इन इंग्लिश को हेल्प कोयल मतलब क्या
फॉलो और किसी भी चीज का फैसला होना है वह
कैसे रहता है कि क्या आपने डायरेक्टर है
इससे कोई भी सेंटेंस ऐसे भी लिखिए लेफ्ट
जो आपने लिखा है उसको कोई लॉजिकल फ्लोर
इसके लिए होते हैं तस्मात् यहां पर हमको
वेरी उसफुल होंगे हमारे जो कंजंक्शंस हमने
सीखा हमने 6 से 7 दो तरीके के कंजंक्शन
सीखे हैं यह आपको यहां पर बहुत यूजफुल
होंगे उसके बाहर आती है व्हाट्सएप
व्हाट्सएप मतलब आपकी मुकाबले है आपकी
वोकैबलरी कितनी बड़ी है और आपको कितने
अलग-अलग तरीके से यूज करते हो और
तो उसका मतलब वह करेक्टली यूज करते हुए
इसका यह पोर्शन और उसके बाद रेस्टोरेंट
उरल मतलब सी के लिए आपका ग्रामर मतलब पर
ग्रामर कितना करेक्ट है आप अलग-अलग तरह
किसी सेंटेंस बनाते हो क्या और अगर आपकी
कुछ गलतियां हो गई है मिली वहीं के बाद वह
बैग में नहीं गया तो इससे आपका सेंटेंस का
मीनिंग आफ लोगों को समझने वह कितना
प्रॉब्लम होता है यह सब ही स्टूडेंट
इंपोर्टेंट चीज है समझ लो इन चारों को
ऑलमोस्ट इक्वल वेटेज है अगर आप देखोगे
10104 10104 10106 दशै तो ऑलमोस्ट
एवरीथिंग अबाउट ट्वेंटी फाइव परसेंट
मार्क्स तो हमेशा याद रखना अनफॉर्चूनेटली
क्या होता है जनरली लोग सिर्फ व्हाट्सएप
पर ध्यान देते हैं पर स्पेशली को रन शोरूम
हमारे मार्ग से उन पर भी ध्यान दें
कि यह समझ में आया तो मेन डिटेल हर एक
टाइम देखते हैं तो सबसे पहले हम देखते हैं
पहली टाइम उसमें आपको क्या करना है आपको
एक ईमेल लिखना है इन फॉर्मल दोस्त को
दोस्त को लिखना है तो किस फॉर्म में
लिखोगे दूर होंगी करें और उसमें जनरली
क्या होता है आपने कोई चीज की होती है कि
आपने कोई कोर्स किया होता है या खराब का
बर्थडे हुआ है आपके घूम के आए हो और आप
अपने दोस्त को पता रहेगा और आपको इसमें से
क्या अच्छा लगा जल्दी और फिर जनरल आप सर्च
करते हो कि क्या हम मिले कि इतने दिन
पॉइंट जनरली होते हैं आप वह इसमें देख
सकते हो अब देखोगे फॉर एग्जांपल इसमें
क्या है देखो कि वह बर्फ का बर्थडे हो गया
था आपको दोस्त को बताना है कि भाई दोस्त
नहीं आ पाया था तो उसको बताना है कि कैसे
वह बर्थडे मुझे कौन सा गिफ्ट सबसे अच्छा
लगा और हैंड में मतलब आगे मिलने के लिए
सजेशन जो सिंपल है राइट टोटल आपको कितने
10 से 15 सेंटेंस बनाना है तीनों पॉइंट्स
कवर करनी हैं तो सबसे पहले आप
तो लिखे इसलिए दोस्तों कि है उसके बाद
क्या दोस्त को लिख रहे तो आपको शुरुआत में
लिखना पड़ेगा क्योंकि प्रिय जो हिंदी में
लिखे हुए मेल है तो लिबर्टी मेल है तो
नींबू मतलब और उससे आप शुरू कर सकते हैं
ओके और फिर शुरू करते हो तो आप जनरली मतलब
फीडबैक करने के लिए विकेट दी है वीकेंड
यार बोल सकते हो कैसा चल रहा है तेरा या
इस्ट बाय थिस आईएस नॉट ट्रू मतलब तुम्हारे
सब कुछ ठीक चल रहा है ना इसे शुरुआत कर
सकते हो और फिर बोल सकते हो क्योंकि
दोस्तों सिंपल है राइड पॉइंट प्रीतम सिंपल
है 11 हां भाई मेरा बर्थडे हुआ बहुत अच्छी
तरह से सेलिब्रेट किया होटल में गया खाना
खाया डांस किया कुछ भी लिख सकते हो और फिर
दूसरा पॉइंट पर बोल सकते हो कि मुझे बहुत
सारी गिफ्ट मिले पर सबसे अच्छा कि मुझे
अपने पापा का लगा कि मुझे उस पसंद है
उन्होंने मुझे एक बुद्धि कोई भी लिख सकें
थे सिंपलेस्ट अरे में बोल सकते हो कि भाई
अरे यार हम मिल सकते हैं नेक्स्ट संडे को
मुझे तुमको फोटो भी दिखाए हैं वह चैनल
2019 आम जामुन स्टेफेन या फिर अगर आपको
कॉफी यूज करना है बी वायरस वेंडेल होम्स
स्टॉक 53 कर सकते हो समझ रहे तो इधर सिंपल
है उसमें कुछ ठीक करने और एंड मैं आप बोल
सकते हो कि भाई डेफिनेटली बोलना मेरे को
याद में विशेष मतलब डेफिनेटली बोलना और
फिर एंड में सिस्टम हिंदी में लिखते हैं
वैसे ही फील कुसैया लिबास उसे लिख सकते हो
मतलब कि वार्म रिगार्ड्स कैसे कैन गो आफ
क्लब रुसया लीवर गुस्सा कि इन इनफॉरमल है
और एडमिन सिर्फ का नाम कि दोस्त को लेकर
अक्सर ने लिखने की जरूरत नहीं है
तो देखा आपने एकदम सिंपल शुरुआत कैसे इन
फॉर्मल मेल है इसलिए लीवर जो भी हो उसके
बाद थोड़ा सा विल गेट एडिक्टेड टो करना
फिर तीनों पॉइंट्स पर लिखना फ्रेंड करते
वक्त कि वह वक्त डिफरेंट के बोल मेरे को
टाइट करना फीलिंग उस फ़ालतू और आपका नाम
लिखना नेट से याद रखना इन्फॉर्मेशन दूसरे
लें एकदम सिंपल है राइट नेक्स्ट जो अब तक
है या नैक जो टाइल है वह एकदम सिंपल है यह
भी उसमें आपको क्या करना होता है जनरली कि
आपको एक अधीन दी होती है कि आपने कोई तो
एक टीवी प्रोग्राम देखा है या ऑनलाइन कोई
तो एक तरफ प्रोग्राम देखा है और उस पर
आपको अपना ओपीनियन लिखना है ऑनलाइन और
अपने गेंद सिर्फ असीमानंद से 15 लाइंस में
लिखना होता है और उन्होंने क्या किया होता
है देखो आपको एक एक्टिव थीम भी होती है और
उसके नीचे किसी एक और प्रसंग का ओपिनियन
झाल अभी इंपोर्टेंट थिंग क्या है वह बंदे
का ऐप ओपन होता है कुछ सिर्फ आपकी हेल्प
के लिए है अगर आपको अगर मतलब और चीज समझ
में नहीं आई यह आपको अपने वर्ड्स कुछ यह
लॉजिक नहीं समझ रहा है उसके लिए आपको उस
तरफ पर्सन क्योंकि नेम को रिएक्ट नहीं
होना है यू डोंट नीड टो थिंक अबाउट द
बिगेस्ट मिस्टेक पीपल डिड ऊ डोंट इवन थिंक
अगर स्पेशली मेरा तो कुछ का मानना यह था
मैं अपने कुछ वैसे करता था उससे फ्रंट को
सरदार अगर आपको देखते ही अगर थीम करेक्ट
समझ में आई वांट थे थीम नीचे का पढ़ने की
जरूरत नहीं और 127 और टाइम अगर थी नहीं
समझ में आ रही है तो आप नीचे का देख सकते
हो वह यह कर सकते हो इंपॉर्टेंट मे है
मैं उस से कुछ लेना-देना नहीं है आप उसमें
फॉर लिखा है इसलिए आपको और लिखने की जरूरत
नहीं है उसने अगेंस्ट विकास देखोगे उसने
कुछ भी नहीं उसको कंट्री मत करो िजस पड़ी
है तो क्या करना है आपको जब लिखना है तो
एकदम सिंपल कोई तिथि मैंने अभी यहां पर है
कि फेस्टिवल और बैडमिंटन मतलब क्या
फिक्स्ड वर्क टाइमिंग तो उस टॉपिक को मानव
लिखना है एकदम सिंपल आपका जो ओपिनियन है
उसके एडवांटेज इस क्या है एक दूसरा घर
डिसाइड अंग्रेजी सीखना है तो फ्रेंड मैं
बोल सकते हो इन समरी आई वांट टू सी द है
एकदम सिंपल है बहुत इंपोर्टेंट थिंग आप
किस साइड से बोलते हो नोबडी केयर्स मतलब
ऐसे भी बोल सकते क्योंकि वह मेरे को तो
लगता है फिक्सिंग और पिछडे वर्ग के परिवार
वेरी गुड प्रथम दृष्टया अपना काम करो काम
करो घर जाओ तुम्हारा अपना एक शेड्यूल होता
है तुमको पता होता है कि मैं कब क्या
करूंगा क्लाइंट के साथ में अपना मीटिंग जो
भी है वह सेट कर सकता हूं सुबह मुझे पता
है क्या करना है शाम को भी मुझे पता है
क्या करना है मैं अपना टाइम टेबल लगा सकता
हूं दस फिर भी अगर हां कभी-कभी प्रॉब्लम
होता है कुछ प्रॉब्लम है तो मैं छुट्टी ले
सकता
कि उसे तो यह भी लिख सकते हो कि नहीं मुझे
तो लगता है कि लेकिन जब लाइनिंग अच्छा है
मेरे को जब लगेगा मैं सुबह काम करूंगा रात
को तो रात को काम करूंगा इट्स अक्टूबर में
राजू सैनी फ्लैक्सिबिलिटी फिर उससे में
डिसाइड कर सकता है कि मेरा कोई इमरजेंसी
है तो मैं खुद जाकर दोपहर में काम कर सकता
हूं उसके लिए मुझे छुट्टी लेने की जरूरत
नहीं है अंदर लाइक एंड आई थिंक कि मैं
बहुत ज्यादा प्रोडक्टिवली काम कर सकता हूं
कि जिसमें फोकस जो भी तुम्हारा है
इंटेसटाइन मैटर इंपोर्टेंट क्या है तुम
तुम्हारा ओपिनियन ठीक से लिख रहा है उसको
डिफरेंट कर रिफंड कर सकूं एडवांटेजेस टो
क्रिएट ए कल्चर विच नहीं दे सकते हैं मैं
दूसरे से किसी भी सोच सकता हूं दिखाने के
लिए Android वंचित कि वही होते हुए तो
उसके लिए क्या करना है नार्मल है मैं खुद
करता था मुझे यह पता लगता है अच्छा तथा इस
विनोद और मालूम था कि मेरा यह मानना है कि
आप उपभोक्ताओं को वगैरह कुछ भी के बीच में
अपना पॉइंट रखना फिर बोल सकते हो इस गिफ्ट
फ्लॉप fertile है उसके बहुत सारे रोमांटिक
जिस है एक दूसरा लिखना है न पहले तो
नैचुरली ही टेस्टी लगता है लास्ट मैच
झालर भी होंगे और एंड मेरा पसंदीदा है जो
विटामिन फसल मिस्टर जालंधर मतलब हम लिंक
समय इन समरी में फिर एक बार बोलना चाहूंगा
कि अब बोल सकते हो मेरी सिंपल एक मतलब
आपको सिर्फ थिंग समझ में लेनी है अगर
डायरेक्ट समझ में आई अच्छी बात है नहीं आई
तो नीचे का इससे पुष्कर वक्त लगा सकते हो
देखो कि डाल डिफरेंस नहीं हुई इसी ओर
कॉन्फिडेंट इनफ डाइरैक्टली सकते हो नहीं
है तो उसके पति से कुछ वर्ड्स वगैरह आप ले
सकते हैं बट दो नॉट कॉपी ई डोंट वांट
हेल्प की समझ रहे इन इंडिया एंड वर्ल्ड
कंप्लीट ने अपना लिखा कि यह सब का अभी
थर्ड सकती इसलिए यह क्या आप कोई फॉर्मल
लेटर लिखना है बिस्मार्क के लिए है 5 से 7
लाइन लिखने आपको 40 वर्ड
का मौसम टाइम्स कंसेप्ट यह होती है कि
आपको किसी ने किसी भी कोई अपॉइंटमेंट दी
है और आप नहीं आ सकते सॉरी बोलना वह बाद
में आऊंगा बोलना है या फिर आपको किसी के
साथ एक अपॉइंटमेंट सेट करनी होती है मेरी
सिंपल ड्राइंग अभी यह फॉर्मल यह फॉर्मल है
तो आप कैसे करोगे जी फोन में आप हमने
करोगी और शुरुआत कैसे करोगे उसके लिए इस
प्रश्र है अगर जनरल वही पर्सन का नाम दिया
होगा तो वह लेडी है तो जहर की हर टपरा
हुड्डा अगर वह जेंट्स है तो जहर क्लियर ट
हेर डॉटर अप कर सकते हो इन वर्ष के अगर
नाम ही नहीं दिया हो तो जैसे इन इंग्लिश
एक्टर सर और मैडम करते हैं वैसे यहां पर
ज़हर गियर दामों ने रंगिया कर सकते हो ओके
यह सिर्फ शुरुआत हुई अभी फॉर्मल लेटर है
तो कोई आइस ब्रेक हो गया करने की जरूरत
नहीं सीधा पॉइंट है वह अभी तक यहां पर
कैसे है कि किसी ने आपको टमी पर बुलाया है
वहां पर आप नहीं आ सकते आप उसको रीजनिंग
देने को बोला है आपको तो और
दोनों अगर चाहिए तो बोल सकते हो कि मैं
मंडे को आउंगी तो सिंपल है एकदम सिंपल
फ्रंट फिर दी अलार्म थैंक्यू अपने बुलाया
हुआ था इंस्टीट्यूट में एलाइड सही बोल
सकते हो इसका नेक्स्ट को में इशारा एंटर
मिनिस्टर आफ वगैरह कर सकते हो अगर यहां पर
भी कलेक्टर सबको यूज होंगे वाइल्ड लोगे तो
बिकॉज़ बोल सकोगे 800 जिस थिंग एकदम सिंपल
एंड में एंड में क्योंकि अगर इन फॉर्मल है
विद फ्रेंड रिक्वेस्ट्स ऐसे पूछ सकते हो
मिनट फ्रॉम इंग्लिश एंड रोशन मीट फाइनली
सिंह रोशन पूरा न कि फॉर्मल है किरदार
ज्यादा एकदम सिंपल अट वेरी सिंपल 5 से 7
बहन आपको सिर्फ लिखने होते हैं मोस्ट
लाइक्ली कि वह बस सॉरी मैं नहीं आ सकता
क्योंकि मैंने बजे हम इस द फॉरेस्ट
ओके खन समझ में आएंगे तो अगर आपको फॉर्मेट
समझ में आया होगा तो थोड़े टिप्स देखते
हैं ऐड बहुत ही सिंपल है अगर आप नार्मल
अपने अगर 5 सेंटेंसेस लिखे हुए हैं तो
आइसक्रीम कुछ अलग करने की जरूरत नहीं है
कि वह क्या यह जो लेजर को करोगे यह बहुत
बड़ा इसका सुपर सेट होगा और कंजंक्शंस अगर
आपने अभी तक के किए हैं न इस वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट करो कि मैं मोबाइल वैन रॉमपॉय
यह सब आपको अगर आता है तो बहुत यूजफुल है
अगर पॉसिबल है तो कोई थे कि वेबसाइट पर भी
आपको दो पेपर समय लेंगे उसके साइड कॉल करो
एक ट्रेडिशनल किया तो अच्छी बात है बट नॉट
रियली ए सहित 11 पैटर्न हैंडसेट है तो आप
वह कर सकते हैं ओके खा भी इन एक्जाम इन
एक्जाम सबसे इंपोर्टेंट चीज है कि वह आपके
पास साइड मिनट है इंजन रस 8 मिनट ऑफ इनकम
क्योंकि आपको सब मिलते कितने अबाउट
ट्वेंटी फाइव 230 मैक्सिमम थर्टी फाइव
लाइंस लेकिन हैं और यू नो ऑल राउंड कि
क्या होने वाला है
हैं तो इसलिए मैं एक्टिव दूंगा
क्विक शांति से सब पढ़ लो समझ लो क्या
करना है हर टास्क में फ्री लीजिए फिर उसके
र प्वाइंट बनाओ आई डोंट बिलीव कि कम से कम
पूरा वह स्टार्ट लिखने की जरूरत नहीं पर
जो पॉइंट्स करने वाले हो वह एटलीस्ट एक
बार रख में लिख क्रॉस क्या होता है जैसे
स्कूल में करते थे न कि ऐड करके उधर जाकर
लिखा है फिर ऑफ किया हुआ अच्छा नहीं लगता
थोड़ा रुक पहले कर लो और फिर आपको जिस
क्रम में लिखना है वह लिख को पहला दूसरा
तीसरा तीसरा दूसरा पहला की इस पैक एक्टिव
मेरे लिए यूज पुष्टि की वहीं फर्स्ट अगर
तरफ 123 लिखा है वह तो पहले एक लिखने के
बाद उसको चेक करने मत जाओ वह कि मिस्टेक
नहीं दिखते पहले एक बहुत ही लिख लो फिर
सेटिंग को जवाब एक दो तीन ठीक है सेकंड
वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट टिप्स इस बहुत ज्यादा
नहीं लिखना कि वह 80 वर्ष लिखे हैं 90 करो
मैक्सिमम शो करो एग्जाम डेट संदेश का नहीं
लिखना मैंने जान-बूझकर अगर आप स्क्रीन पर
दिख रहा होगा कि यह उसी
हां यह क्रिस्पी आंसर शीट के सैंपल आंसर
चेहरा देखो मैं कितनी छोटे-छोटे हैं यह
याद रखना यह पूरे देखने की जरूरत नहीं है
डेस्टाइनड टो कि इतने छोटे होते हैं तो आप
10 से प्रणाम व लायंस मतलब 10 से 15 लें
ज्यादा लिखोगे तो मेन प्रॉब्लम है कि आपके
ज्यादा मिस्टेक होंगे ज्यादा मार्केटिंग
रेट तो बहुत ज्यादा भी मत लेना ओके खा
अन्यथा इंपोर्टेंट थिंग डॉट राइट योर
कॉन्टैक्ट्स समझ में लोगों को ना बहुत बार
बहुत ज्यादा बड़े-बड़े वर्ड यूज़ करने की
आदत होती है मन जैसा मैंने बोला कि यह
व्हाट्सएप से गुड थिंग बट जस्ट पार्ट आफ
ऑल स्कीम 25परसेंटेज मोड को आयरन सरल पीले
फूलों की नई इंपोर्टेंट है कभी कि विकल्प
है क्योंकि यह वर्ड मुझे अच्छा आता है
इसलिए लोग उसको डालना चाहते डॉन दाउद है
यह आपके नॉर्मल प्रूफ देता एकता ₹500
अच्छे जा रहे हैं अच्छी बात है पर सिर्फ
व्हाट्सएप सी शराब नहीं है यह मत भूलिएगा
इंपोर्टेंट क्या है
कि किस सारे पॉइंट्स तोड़ कर ना बैठ ए
very-very इंपोर्टेंट की वजह से मैंने
बोला कि मैं पहले करती पॉइंट पर लिखना है
अगर आपने हमारा बर्थडे इतना अच्छा हुआ इस
पर 10 12 लाइन लिख दिए और फैशन के बारे
में नहीं लेता तो प्रॉब्लम है स्मरण कंवर
ऑल द प्वाइंट्स इन ऑल गर्ल टॉक पहले सिले
शांति से पढ़ लो दैट इज द मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट हैं और एंड थे जो मेरी खुद को
मेरी फेवरेट टिप है कि कम से कम 5 मिनट
आयुष से 5 मिनट अगर पॉसिबल को 10 मिनट
लास्ट में सिर्फ चैटिंग के लिए शांत दिमाग
से चेकिंग के लिए लगना है और वहां पर क्या
चेक करना है हमको पीछे गहने मोस्ट इन
इंग्लिश में लिखा होता है तो इंग्लिश में
ना जो नॉर्मल फंड्स होते वह कैपिटल नहीं
होते हैं पर जर्मन में होते हैं वह आपको
चेक करना पड़ेगा कि नॉर्मल है वह गलत हो
जाता है फिर स्पेलिंग चेक करने फिर बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट है जब लिखते हो दोनों भी थकान
करेक्ट लगता है कि वे कैन किया होता है ना
तो इसीलिए शांति से कि वह सब वर्ग ठीक से
कंजरवेटर यह क्या देखना अगर आपने वायरल
जैसे कलेक्टर यूज किए हैं तो मैं जो व
चलने वाला है वेस्ट में गया है ना देखना
और वह ट्वीट किया कितना भी प्रेक्टिस करो
यह वहां पर थोड़े मिस्टेक होंगे ही यह
प्लेट होता है और लिखते वक्त तो याद नहीं
है आपके लिए शांति से उसको जो एक्स्ट्रा
पैरों फैजाबाद एक्सप्रेस तो नहीं है तो
इसलिए हम यह फिर से करेंगे तो पुलिस
चेकिंग बहुत इंपोर्टेंट है उससे आप जो
अपने अपने खुद के ही जो मिस्टेक्स करेक्ट
करोगे उतने अपने मार्ग बचने वाले कि वह
म्यूट एक तरफ का एग्जामिनर निकालने वाला
था समझ में आया अगर आपने इतना किया है तो
बहुत ही स्ट्रेट फॉरवर्ड ऐड यू हैव इनफ
टाइम आपको पता है ऑलमोस्ट क्या करना है
अपनी प्रैक्टिस करके जा सकते हो वहां पर
शांत रहना है सिर्फ सारे पॉइंट्स पर
लॉजिकली अगर आप लिखकर आए और मिक्सचर किया
कि वह आधा फालतू के ग्रामेटिकल मिस्टेक्स
नहीं कर रहे हो तो विशुद्ध वेरी इजी एंड
स्कोरिंग टॉपिक मुझे आशा है कि आपको यह
शराब एवं अच्छी तरह समझ में आया होगा next
पाठ में हम परेशान
10 वी